and I'm family what's going on man hey
buddy how are you let's see man hi oh my
god what are you wearing just these you
can't get those what are Ermac are they
Air Jordans or they don't know they're
like run run it more like a running shoe
but you wouldn't really these are like a
sportswear running shoe yeah I go with
the New Balance I mean I'm a big New
Balance guy you got white feet my son is
pretty much only rock new glasses yeah
my [ __ ] shoes wide feet pork feet
Rockport ports or New Balance yeah are
the [ __ ] everyone's been giving me
the business oh you picked bad New
Balance because I imagined like those
gray ones there that are totally
passable you can get New Balance that
look cool
yeah I did but you it would actually
look like you wanted to not specifically
not do that I think it makes a lot of
sense now that you reference Rockport
right after yeah because when you lifted
those up I thought they were rock cause
you did right yeah I used to be able to
wear a lot but they're so heavy and they
just not as coming I love I had one pair
of Doc Martens that I've had since I was
16 and I've resold them like I took the
Doc Martens soul out and now it's just
like a Wolverine boot sole and I've had
them you know almost twenty years are
the best they all right yeah I love I
just think they look the coolest yeah
there's still something like since I'm a
punk rock about him you know well I
don't wear it that much because I'm not
punk rock like that but like I like it
how old is your son
six okay yeah why he's already got wide
feet oh yeah he born he came out with
white feet oh my gosh no white he's like
a he's a big dude because you can't buy
just go out and buy anything we'll just
walk by xu7 like a misshapen shape me
feel weird feet I have an odd body I
have an incredibly long torso like I am
alter shockingly low have six feet of
torso photoshopped
and then I have it also like a really
long head not wide it's not just
everything's like like you're going into
a black hole right now I like the
space-time continuum is like round my
face yeah are you a sneaker guy or you
just saw those kneeling I am I like that
you know IIIi feel like sneakers are
something like culture culturally
probably for people our age you just you
guys in our age group probably Jim
you're you're more that Rockport age I
don't know you saw the way I leaned and
said guys our age not super psyched
about it over here either I'm 36 yeah
sorry it's group no I'm 34 that's yes
you're 34 I am he looks older right no I
look terrible
I don't think oh thanks for ending but
it's a yeah getting old it's terrible
you wouldn't believe how old I am i I
don't want to know I don't want to know
because I feel like you don't age like I
feel like I've known you at this like
body and shape my entire comedy life you
know weight much fatter you were a
bigger
unlike Colin Quinn yeah what was the
name unfuckable piggy boy do you ever do
stand-up you did I really did stand-up I
would say I
I came up at UCB in like like sketch and
improv and that kind of like yeah I
guess they called it like alt comedy
writer singer book in that room you
remember Jeff singer booking on the
pianos or whatever no yes that was the
state yeah the state guys did that like
yeah they that was um like David Wain
and Showalter had had a show down there
somewhere and then Michael a black and
and like um I don't so I never did
stand-up like that but but the I was
doing that kind of comedy was just
different at the time yeah I wish I did
stand-up I I feel like I I it's too it's
too hard to start now like you got
you gotta be really bad at it and then
get really good at it and I don't have
kids and like I am you tired yeah you
have time to do that I don't have time
to be better and I don't want to just do
it in that way we're like all of a
sudden I'm like I stand up you know it
feels like not there is a celebrity
thing to where you could because you've
been on TV and stuff get people in a
room and get some joke writers to do it
for you and you could just but it's not
really stand-up it's not really stand-up
it's like more of an appearance but like
I still I've been I've been doing like
some some live shows in New York lately
that have been really fun and weird and
chaotic but um it's it's not stand-up
it's like I'm an amalgamate it's like
improvising it's it's mostly bits just
doing bits like I guess this is what it
is yeah I mean look you've good improv
is really hard I've said that before
it's [ __ ] really did see the great or
it's awful yeah it's awful it's and and
and and even when it's good there is a
sense of like I don't know it's some
it's kind of corny
you know like in in the best way in a
way like you you got to embrace that
it's it's corny but like yes it's dorky
it's a dorky thing to do like improv
comedy it's it's only become cool in the
last like five year five years when
people are starting to succeed off of it
right but but it's not a cool thing you
know like pretending to be a robot is
like not oh it's not cool no you know
and and the best improvisers are the
ones who do the best robots you know and
so they're essentially like not that
cool that's one of those things though
that no matter what it is if you can do
something well people will think it's
cool if you're very good at something
you can convince people that it's cool
it's the people that aren't that good or
only okay sure to really point out that
this is not that cool yeah yeah sure
totally I that is a very astute be good
at what you do my job Joseph D'Angelo
would always say that be good at what
you tell what is worse see now he's in
California's fun he just was arrested
he's the Golden State killer
Joey Joey that's really speaking of
being good at what you do I
last night I was doing my my googling of
you you know I just sound like it wasn't
for this show and that's one thing you
do like nightly google him catches me
bid show my kid off your phone we know
it's fine yeah everything's okay but I
was overjoyed to view your appearance on
the shorty award the Shorty Awards
elected Twitter big yeah I burned a
bridge Adam went up and did it's like 10
minutes yeah I mean it was a long time
yeah but just immediately from the time
you got there you were [ __ ] all over
and not in like a fun way you know oh I
hate this place way well over everything
I you know I really it's tough like I I
was really just goofing around you know
and and the vibe of the room was very
loose and the right before I went on
someone was like you know go be funny
you know and I was like okay and the
funniest thing about what was going on
that night was that like I wasn't gonna
go on and do material and like you know
and that's why they brought me in was to
you know be funny and I've seen my fair
share of award shows like I knew where
we were in the paradigm of what was
going on yeah you know but I do feel I
do feel bad that people whose job it is
to do that stuff and like I didn't want
like I didn't want to my goal was not to
make anyone feel bad about their job
yeah you know I didn't I'm glad you did
but um so good because uh like there's
been a it's weird it's like the internet
choose you out it you know it I I didn't
expect to get mad at you yeah not only
the content creators but like multiple
there's like a bunch of negative it
wasn't a great thing like my family
wasn't psyched to read headlines Adam
pally gets kicked off of award show
right alike and so but you didn't
actually not want to be there no look
I'm promoting a movie and it was part of
the press junket and I knew what I was
doing like sigh a lot of people like
why'd he even goes like well I went to
do that why I was there I went to be
funny and that's end to me like it's
funny and I look back at it and I go fun
II the bummer of it to me to be on it
besides besides the fact that people are
were offended which I really honestly
like did not
I was just joking around and you can
either take it as a joke or not but I'm
not gonna apologize for it
the bummer of it was that like I was one
sentence away from being done right and
I think it wouldn't have been as big a
story I think it would have just been a
funny bit at an award show but if you
watch it what actually happens is the
singer she does not work for the award
show she's just a singer who won an
award earlier in the night so imagine
like the Internet's Kesha okay you know
sitting at the Grammys she sees what's
happening and she thinks she's going to
run on and save the day because it sent
out there by the show no she did it on
her own and when she gets up there she
starts reading the copy and she goes
this is really inappropriate now but we
are doing an in memoriam she didn't know
that the in memoriam wasn't as a GUI it
was a goof and and so she kind of like
made it seem like it was something it
wasn't right like and so that was why I
got removed and like it was like I was
like oh you and that was the bummer the
whole thing was like it would have just
been a funny bit so it should be an
[ __ ] no no I I don't think she's been
here so I think she was like didn't know
it's like she'd quite get what was going
on yeah what was going on she didn't get
what I was doing and she really thought
that I was about to make a mockery of an
in memoriam I don't know in her mind who
they were going to in memorialize right
but I was clearly joke
around about the fact that they were in
memorializing with their so what they
did was they did like an immemorial of
social media sites that are no longer
active which is like MySpace and Sangha
and like those web sites and Adam does
this thing where he's like he starts
reading the teleprompter and then he's
like exhausting because I don't know
we're gonna do some [ __ ] where we put up
MySpace and stuff and kind of made a
goof on it but as he's doing that this
girl walks out of nowhere and just goes
like ah they wanted me to come and save
the show and then she does the thing
where she says this is really awkward
she was this notion this is
inappropriate inappropriate
inappropriate yeah so she thinks we're
going to an immemorial
we're going to an actual in memoriam and
so that was the other bummers like you
can't even I don't want to say this
without being crude and then I kinda
don't want to talk about it because I
don't want it like this to be my I
really don't want to be known as the
shortest guy the bummer of it is that
you can't even really joke around you
can't even really do comedy in that
space anymore because people can't even
get they they they can't even get a joke
they're dopes it's like there's a there
so they they don't even they can't even
see what is happening there's just like
this wide I like there's no base level
of reality yeah so you can't joke around
because it's all just like you know
floating you know it's like I was just
really mystified at the fact that like
people didn't get it or people were like
at one point in the middle of Adams
presentation of the award he's like
doing the whole thing and then he just
kind of stops and he's like I know I'm
up here and I'm killing just you know
we're killing uh
yeah the way I wanted to be yeah yeah
you know like people laughing
uncomfortable I was a hearty amount of
both the people that I wanted to laugh
were dying like The Daily Show dudes and
like their staff that was there and and
like the queer eye guys who I think are
funny like they loved it and that to me
was like and that's me was where my
barometer was because I had seen the
rest of the room where I was like oh I
don't care
I think cuz he goes where he goes like
I'm up here killing and he goes but if
you guys are gonna come to me and ask me
to host this thing next year it's a hard
pass I want to work I I got kids I
really like that's the issue right you
were trying to be funny not like declare
war yeah yeah and I am not like you know
I am NOT like the brand anti brand guy
like I love brands like I'm all branded
out I love brands and I love popular
culture and I'm on Twitter and Instagram
sometimes I wish I wasn't but I am and
that's not me either I was just simply
you know doing a bit and and and in and
this will this will make it worse
because people will uh will will be
upset that I was doing a like this what
I've done right now today he was made it
worse but it's really it's okay like as
she said they were dopes you're fine no
I you said that I knew great but no
because it's because I don't know I
really like I I wasn't seeking to hurt
anybody right
I was just seeking a like a bit of
comedy you making fun of something I was
making fun of yeah you know and and and
I was hoping and I and I and I was and I
know that not everybody's gonna love
everything right but I also like and I
and I know as a comic for my entire life
that I that I don't shouldn't care right
but for some reason I do feel like
bummed out by it it bums me out he bums
you out there was such a negative
response to something you're doing it'd
be funny and just being stupid about
something and the people like oh well
that was terrible like yeah it's like I
said but it's like I can't I don't want
it like I was getting all these nice
emails from from from like it was the
best phone day I've ever had you know
we're like names pop up and you're like
oh my god yeah you know and you're like
wow reading this stuff and then you're
and then the negative stuff starts to
roll in and it's just like you go
I don't know man I'm tired is it worth
it is it worth it to just be like the
the the point of a think piece about you
know creating brands and like is it
worth it to get Google Alerts from like
people writing articles saying that I
look like I hadn't showered and like I
respect that is it worth it that's the
better you show up at an award show
messy and make fun of it that's great
yeah it is great like that's and it like
and like me who I am was like yeah great
mom we as security was walking at my
wife but like I love it you know that's
who we are it's really my wife arts it
but it also I just it bums me out
because I'm like oh man um I don't know
where the intention is not to like make
anybody feel bad
yeah just want like let's have a laugh
at this but like the fact that you look
at this you know like I don't know like
like Ricky Gervais goes on the Golden
Globes and like eviscerates it he get
[ __ ] for throw to people do come back
you go that was mean or like she helps
Mel Gibson after he did that bit with
Mel he's trying to fold it I don't can
eat a dick right you don't mind Mel
Gibson being the enemy no no no I just
turned down and I did not I'm not apart
I just turned down an audition for a
male gay I felt it was a good director
job itself
oh come on turn it down really yeah I
don't need that [ __ ] in my life doesn't
blow your mind that who can make
comebacks and who can't
yeah you know what I mean like you would
think that Mel Gibson because he's
because Mel Gibson is a great actor I
need a good director also people don't
mind hating Jews you think that's yeah
it's like that's one of the things
people don't know he's probably doesn't
think that way anymore
right right like we all assume now Mel
Gibson doesn't think that way that could
be a temporary right you're like he was
drunk he got pulled over um yeah yeah
definitely still thinks that way if you
listen to any of those tapes the way he
talked to Oksana he's not a good singer
no she's right and she needed to be told
fairness if you want your dick sucked
before a woman goes in your jacuzzi
yeah that is your right sure no no Yuri
and she should have been listen
I guess that's the problem they weren't
communicating right right but that's but
I you know I don't who would want that
[ __ ] like that isn't some of the worst
[ __ ] I've ever heard in my life why
would anybody go near I don't need any
of that right in my life and frankly I'm
like slightly disappointed that people
are like cool with it
you know why it doesn't bother me only
because if there's an ugliness and it
says I'll do great with a lot of it um
no I got all that no but if there's an
ugly this they're like it's just dumb
[ __ ] that he said there's so much
ugliness in show business and in music
and in hip-hop and in comedy there's so
many dark ugly secrets that a guy just
with a being a dick it doesn't bother me
as much because if I start to worry
about that Who am I gonna work with like
I there's a lot to work with it agreed I
agree with a lot of what you're saying
however I think as a Jew and I'm not
even Jewish yeah man I'm [ __ ] assured
me of something it's not it's not even
offensive it's just like you know you're
right there's so much there's so much
hate and ugly [ __ ] and it is just like a
dark thing but there's also like not
that much time to to waste on [ __ ] like
I don't what it's just nasty vile crap
and like he definitely still thinks that
way and and I don't want to be on set
and hear him like screaming at someone I
don't want to be involved in that if you
Jewish and you look at Mel Gibson and go
[ __ ] that guy I don't like the way he
thinks III understand that like that yes
it's like that's it um and also you
don't really get into show business to
have that energy around you right yeah
and like the people are gonna be like
the guy from the Shorty Awards doesn't
want to work with Mel Gibson but like
yeah they're completely they're totally
different I would say what you did is
not as bad as what Mel Gibson did well
you should read some of the
so my hat mentioned it I think maybe
worse yeah oh for sure P we think you
can hear I would bet I bet you if you
took a poll people are so not that
pissed about jew-hating that if you took
a poll right now I bet you people would
say that what I did was worse than what
Mel Gibson - so you can insult Jews you
can't insult the Internet
exactly Wow it's so cool to insult juice
it's like it is like it is one of the
hottest thing right now like is it dude
Kanye is two seconds away from insulting
the Jews do you think that's where he's
gonna go now yes who else has insulted
them publicly because I know that does
happen like who else do you think is
like wow that's [ __ ] up
I mean cardi B is one of my favorite
rappers right I think she's the best
rapper to come out in in definitely last
year but to come out of New York in the
last 12 years right since ASAP like she
is the best rapper regard the best first
line of like track three my lawyer is a
Jew he don't you this whole place up
that's there like that is that it he's
gonna do this whole place up yeah so
funny like if you again I always really
need to stand up that's the only way I
but you imagine that like how upset
people would get but what she said says
oh look - it was like and I am not
religious I don't believe in the
religion right I am a Jew I am a Jew the
reason that I am a Jew is because my
family is Jewish I know when the [ __ ]
hits the fan they're gonna come for me
yeah so that's why I'm Jewish the first
line in a major song is like my lawyer
is a Jew and so you're like listening to
it you're like whoa dude well why what
is that significance not that I can't
like I really don't care jay-z is not
disparaging jay-z's a legend and his
billionaire status that did not bother
me and now he's rapping about the fact
that like he's bragging that he has Jews
that handle his finances place up the
what is that like did no way to its
positive in a positive way like he's
like like she's like it's the same boast
like when she's like I like those
Balenciaga cos the ones that look like
socks
she's equated that to having a Jewish
lawyer right you know it was like good
thing a good thing but also it's
like a microaggression why are we
wrapping up it's basically taking a
stereotype that Jews love money and her
lawyers and even though you're doing
something positive with it you're still
taking a stereotype that's been [ __ ]
horrible and hurtful for sure and using
it first and like and it's so chill now
it's like the chillest thing hip hop
almost never gets in trouble for it they
say there's a different standard to hip
hop then there is to any other group
fine
that that that I won't argue with you on
that because I think that you're
probably right and that's okay with me
too and I'm not upset at cardi B for for
writing a Jew line I I love that album
and I love her and like I'm gonna take
my son to see your concert when she
plays with Bruno Mars that's awesome but
I I also am like it's more of a societal
thing where I'm like oh we're all that's
all that's cool now cuz when I was a kid
that was like not cool
you could not say that if someone was
like I have a lawyer a jeweler that's
gonna do this place up ACLU like you
know like not cool so or the
anti-defamation league I'm surprised
they haven't said anything because those
guys are usually uh there's too much to
worry B is on the bottom thing in like
20 minutes outside of Atlanta they're
burning swastikas like they don't care
it's so chill to hate Jews supposed to
get burning so people really think
they're bringing back Nazism like the
nicest but the Nazis are just it's a
shitty ideology like they like the
American people don't think that makes
them look cool I disagree
American Nazism is so close to happening
i-i've done this bit before so I don't
want you like not doing this bit but I
really do believe this that when America
when all like ahh when all the
apocalyptic [ __ ] eventually does happen
and and like if it does go bad no I mean
I won't phrase it it it will let's say
if it does if Trump does lead us into
that direction purposefully or not we
end up being a thing we're like the
economy crashes and they're like the
Jews let's say that happens in America
it's not so far-fetched that people have
have likened pre-world War Two Germany
to America right now a lot so let's say
that happens
the people that will be knocking on my
door and jamming on my floor boards are
SigEp Arizona State hundred that you
would be like using your breath I know
but that is true khakis and polos no no
not khakis impose surfer dudes like look
at those tapes from Syracuse like the
those dudes that are like making people
wear flat face Rose rose they that is
who is going to be like wear your papers
well let me ask you so those guys making
a dumb joke it was tasteless no it's not
though it's how cuz that different then
cardi B who's actually making regional
I'll tell you I'll tell you how because
there's an ideology and them to me that
that what we saw that's a tip of the the
iceberg of the stuff that's probably
going on in that frappe there's an
ingrained sort of way of thinking that's
coupled with that that carbon how is
that what she's doing at the tip of the
iceberg and hip hop with anti-semitism
especially when a lot of people in
hip-hop embrace Farrakhan and he's been
known to be anti-semitic you don't like
the Syracuse guys are dicks but I'm
serious just being tasteless but they're
violent and like in Germany the Syracuse
guys yes dude they are frat dudes or
violence they like they're the right
guys have been violent and the language
is he more also like the people that
kind it's like in Germany when that
happened everyone was like who's
rounding up these Jews like where where
are all these Nazi soldiers coming from
and and what they like the Gestapo like
who what is that who is that well it's
normal Germans who got caught up and
you're like that could never happen but
it happens and the people that get
caught up like that who have like
tendencies already to like group around
it's like that's what that is the fat
guys though a lot of these frat guys
would not behave the way they behaved in
that video if they were on their own yes
right there's being dicks in that video
like in that video they're not calling
for violence then they're just being
there doing things that they consider
shocking and inappropriate to try to be
funny because there's the same reaction
to that people get when they're singing
out loud and they're saying
inappropriate words to they're singing a
rap song
like girl is using the n-word because
she's singing a Kanye song people I go
but I think the slow part yeah is weird
that is a tough one for me I just my
policy as a Jew none I don't won't
classify white as a Jew I don't say it I
just skip sure that's like my policy and
I'm cool with whatever anybody does
because music is tough and it's hard and
like but it just makes me uncomfortable
when I look at video like tape of
Coachella and it's like a hundred
thousand teenage white people you know
just I don't know why it just does they
shouldn't put it in the lyrics if they
don't want because it's almost like look
heavy metal doesn't mind people who are
Catholic kids singing about the devil
right so it's almost like if they don't
want people to sing it just don't put it
in the lyrics like that's fair well I
would never I sure I would never make a
rule about it because it's like you
could do whatever you want but I would
say that everybody needs to reconcile
their own way that they deal with that
issue
white people yeah you you you if you
like hip-hop music and I love hip-hop
music it's it's all I'm a fat guy that's
a finding out my age is coming out even
without you trying it's just like
leaking from you yeah like I that's what
I was raised on that's what I love I'm
ingrained in the culture that's all I do
all day like my Instagram is just like
music video um thoughts and sneakers and
you know like I am involved I like that
that's what I love but so I feel that
you have a responsibility to the culture
to to decide how you're going to deal
with that issue
sure okay that's fair yeah however you
want to do it yeah okay I don't care for
me I don't like it right but but I don't
think I think you're right about the
like people looking for what's the
steadfast rules everyone like that's
like and people want that so that so
that they can really just sing along but
I'm we're talking about the anger that
like the outrage that comes like yeah
that's so upset of the girl on a vine
video yeah or these frat guys who are
just being [ __ ] but there is a
difference between the frat guys and the
girls singing what guys were just they
were laughing like it wasn't like people
left when they like shot people you know
slope argument is if people start
laughing
at violent end because they're the other
they weren't being violent they were
just doing dinosaur but then felt a
shock but there's a big you know same
group of people have you drink to death
sometimes or run naked and do sense babe
that's the point
yeah the cardi B does people don't make
you drink to death no but cardi B people
a lot of them are gangsters and they're
talking about shooting people well yeah
but that's their own story I don't know
I don't I disagree on this issue I feel
like the the history of frat violence
and and stuff is it is a real like red
flag when it comes to the this issue of
no no I you're right but also Jam Master
Jay was murdered to hotter murders yeah
I think he was murderers like there's a
lot of yes it's real they all say posing
with gang sign yeah and the guns it's
like no I don't love that so they're
embarrassing not only violent again I
don't mind it I'm gonna [ __ ] a lot of my
it's worthy legitimately came from
Fahrenheit but let's not pretend that
the frats are embracing something worse
than guys who are holding guns when half
of their friends have been killed well
but one one seems reactionary like one
seems systemically reactionary you know
to me the frat it's like the gun I don't
know I think that's just my my view on
ISM is that is that the there's when I
see a rapper with guns in cash it's
worrisome but it's not as worrisome as
10 young dumb white dudes and I think
that's also because in deep down a lot
of people have a higher expectation of
white people maybe I think people that's
I think is extraordinarily that's a
really dangerous thing I think if we
have a higher expectation of white
behavior like all those white guys are
terrible a black guys that's what they
do I think that's really dangerous like
I don't hold the frat guys to any higher
level I hold them almost to a lower one
because they're [ __ ] young dumb
college kids as opposed to a guy who's
making three million dollars a year I
don't but I'm not on my rap I don't care
what the rap is fine but I don't know
lower standard I don't know I think that
I think if there is that lower standard
view where it's like you expect more
from the frat person that you know it's
like that's a false expectations and I
don't know it's like that's a false
sense of security to be like I feel like
this
is better especially when the the the
that there's a gang mentality different
and I don't mean gang like the gangs of
hip-hop I mean like gang thought like I
don't know that video were there all
laughing scared me more it's just like
put them up and you know it scared me
more don't you think that there's a
difference between people who grew up
with gangs around them and it's just
like this is I thought this was what
life was versus guys who end up going to
a frat and like develop this sort of
they're just doing what they consider
shocking stupid humor it's shocking and
it's stupid I was in a frat at the
University of Arizona which is like no
joke that's like you know they shut the
frat down because it was like legit frat
[ __ ] and never once was anything like
that even remotely and and and they were
like you know it was frat [ __ ] that kind
of goes to the point where I know we
have to wrap up without him - I'm sorry
that we do I love it I love coming to
talk to you guys a part of it is to
though that those words now are so
frowned on that that's the shocking
thing to do
where's 15-20 years ago or even when I
was a kid if you said the word black
guys would either hit you for it or
you're like shut the [ __ ] up much but
now it's like this is shocking I never
felt that yeah I think it's more than
rebellion to like from that group and
and now I've alienated a whole group of
I watched the movie last night thank you
very much I'm gonna tell you that none
of what we've talked about is in the
movie is likely to murder by the way
it's available in digital DVD and it's
on demand may fight Hallie I on Twitter
I had multiple multiple moments
throughout like I didn't really I didn't
know anything about what it was uh-huh
and you can't really tell what it is
based on the poster or anything I'm like
is this like a horror movie or like yeah
it's it's an old-school like murder
mystery but it's hilarious yeah thank
you thank you times it's basically a guy
go did you you didn't did you film it we
filmed here did you come in Westchester
we filmed it in East Chester we no one
talks about East Chester good
East Chester for your
is in Westchester man I used to live
there oh cool so I went like in the
beginning when you started going through
all that yeah yeah yeah oh yeah we
wanted to we really wanted to make a
movie here yeah it was so it's it's a
guy right he's in Caillou's to be the
popular guy in high school 20 years
later or so he goes back and he's not
cool anymore but then he also thinks he
discovered a murder it's it's that story
it's it's really great it's really
really good